with permission mr speaker i would like
to make a statement
updating the house on the government's
humanitarian response to the terrible
unjust war that putin is waging in
ukraine
we are united across this house in the
horror of what is happening the whole
country and the whole country stands
with the heroic people of ukraine and mr
speaker i've literally just come from a
meeting with our dear friend and
colleague the ukrainian ambassador to
london and i've just heard first hand
some of the real pressures and the
tensions inside of the country
putin must fail in his assault on
ukraine
working closely with the ukrainian
government and allies in the neighboring
region
the united kingdom is standing shoulder
to shoulder with ukraine
sending military support defensive
military aid
training thousands of ukrainian troops
as well as introducing one of the
toughest sanction regimes in the world
we are supporting nato partners pressing
for more economic reform and energy
independence in ukraine banning aeroflot
and calling for an end to russian
involvement in the swift banking system
we will continue to think robustly and
creatively about what more we can all do
and as i said in the house yesterday the
government will bring forwards
amendments to the visa penalty measures
in the nationality borders bill so that
we can slow down and effectively stop
the processing of russia visa russian
reasons
of any state that poses a threat to our
national security or the interests of
our allies across the world
the government of ukraine has requested
that the russian government be suspended
from interpol a position the uk
wholeheartedly endorses and we are
rallying other international partners to
also call for the same and support
mr speaker yesterday i announced the
first phase of a bespoke humanitarian
support package for the people of
ukraine
having listened carefully to the arts
and the requests of the ukrainian
government
we have already made significant and
unprecedented changes to the immigration
system
we have helped hundreds of british
nationals and their family members
resident in ukraine to leave the country
with home office staff working around
the clock to assist them
the right honourable member for
normanton ponte fratton castle for
raised a specific case yesterday and i'm
pleased to confirm the person concerned
has been able to travel to the uk
family members of british nationals
resident in the ukraine who need a uk
visa can apply through the temporary
location in la viv or through visa
application centers in poland moldova
romania and hungary
we have created additional capacity in
all locations at pace in anticipation of
the invasion of ukraine
this includes
this includes a pop-up visa application
center in reservoir in poland which has
provided total capacity
currently well over three thousand
appointments per week
our contingency plans have been enacted
now and they're expected to further
increase total capacity to 6000
appointments a week
this week starting this week
by contrast
demand across these locations is usually
approximately 890 biometric appointments
per week there remains availability for
appointments and walk-ins across every
location
should more capacity required we will of
course deliver it and mr speaker i
should also add at this stage as well we
have our rapid deployment deployment
teams already in the region in fact the
fcgo sent them in a few weeks ago to
support this whole effort
i've also removed the usual language
requirements and salary thresholds to
come to the uk to be with their family
members and where family members of
british nationals do not meet the usual
eligibility criteria but do pass all
security checks we will give them
permission to enter the uk outside the
usual rules for 12 months
this means that british nationals and
any person settled in the uk can bring
over immediate ukrainian family members
through this policy alone an additional
100 000 ukrainians could be eligible to
come to the uk and access work and
public services
there is no limit on the numbers
eligible under this route mr speaker
anyone in the ukraine intending to apply
under the family migration route should
contact the dedicated
24-hour home office line for assistance
before applying
ukrainian nationals already in the uk
have been given the option to switch
free of charge to a point space
immigration route or a family visa route
visas for ukrainian temporary workers in
some sectors are being extended so that
they can stay until at least the 31st of
december this year as i said yesterday
i've heard some members calling for visa
waivers
with russian
russian troops are seeking to infiltrate
and merge with ukrainian forces
extremists are on the ground in the
region too
mr speaker i'll continue and perhaps the
party member the opposite party members
i'll take their questions later on but i
actually do want to emphasize the the
seriousness of the security situation on
the ground and that is not something
that can be discounted likely at all mr
speaking
extremists are on the ground and they
are in the region too and i'm sure the
party opposite wanted a security
briefing
from our colleagues we'd happily provide
one but but at the same time i'm very
skeptical of how they treat and respect
security advice
given this and also with putin's
willingness to do violence on british
soil and in keeping with our approach
which we have retained consistently
throughout all emergency activations
including that of in afghanistan we
cannot suspend any security of biometric
biometric checks on people we welcome to
our country we have a collective duty to
keep the british people safe and this
approach is based on the strongest
security advice
mr speaker these measures have been
designed to enable swift implementation
and that is the point swift
implementation without the need for
legislation or changes to immigration
rules the ukrainian people need help
immediately and we are bringing this in
place now
as outlined by the prime minister
earlier today i can also set out phase
two of our bespoke humanitarian support
package for the people of ukraine
firstly we are establishing an expansive
ukrainian family scheme so that british
nationals and people settled in the uk
can bring a wider group of family
members to the uk extend ineligibility
to parents grandparents adult offspring
siblings and their immediate family
members again the scheme will be free
those joining family in the uk will be
granted leave for an initial period of
12 months they will be able to work and
access public funds
secondly we will establish a
humanitarian sponsorship pathway which
will open up a route to the uk for
ukrainians who may not have family ties
with the uk but who are able to match
with individuals charities businesses
and community groups
those who come under this scheme will
also be granted lee for an initial
period of 12 months and they will be
able to work and have access to public
services
the home office will work closely with
all our international partners on the
ground to ensure that displaced
ukrainians
that are in need of a home are supported
my colleague the secretary of state for
leveling up will work with the devolved
administrations to ensure that those who
want to sponsor an individual or family
can volunteer and be matched quickly
with ukrainians in need
there will be no numerical limit on this
scheme and we will welcome as many
ukrainians as wish to come and have
match sponsors
making a success of the new humanitarian
sponsorship pathway will require a
national effort from the entire country
and mr speaker our country will rise to
that challenge
mr speaker this is a very generous and
this is an expansive and unprecedented
package
it will mean that the british public and
the ukrainian diaspora can support
displaced ukrainians in the uk
until they are able to return to a free
and a sovereign ukraine
we are striking a blow
for democracy and freedom against
tyranny
above all we are doing right by the
courageous people of ukraine
we will help british nationals and their
families to get out of ukraine safely
we will support our displaced ukrainian
friends we will robustly we will respond
robustly to russian threats here
in the uk we mr speaker will not back
down we will do what is right and mr
speaker i commend this statement to the
house